Speaker 1: We have more reason to believe
that the most serious investigation of the
attempts to steal the 2020 election are happening
in Georgia.
The fake electors have now been subpoenaed
And we're going to talk about it.
This is correct.
This is a good thing.
But to contextualize, I've continued to insist
that the most likely orange or origin of charges,
high level criminal charges against the top
people in the Trump administration are most
likely to come from the Georgia investigation.
That's the one word Donald Trump famously
said on the phone, I need 1107 11,780 votes.
Gimme a break.
That's the one where Lindsey Graham, the senator
from South Carolina, called to see, well,
what could be done there.
That's the one that really seems most obviously
criminal and most provably criminal.
And that Georgia investigation continues to
signal that it is the most likely place where
charges may stem.
NBC News reporting Georgia fake electors hit
with subpoenas in criminal probe.
This move indicates the district attorney
is homing in on potential charges related
to the alleged plot by Trump's team to overturn
the 2020 election.
Nearly a dozen of Georgia's fake electors
revealed Tuesday they've been subpoenaed to
appear before the Fulton County special grand
jury hearing evidence in the criminal investigation
into 2020 interference by Trump and his allies.
The revelation came in a court filing where
attorneys for 11 of the state's 16 false presidential
electors tried to quash subpoenas, calling
them unreasonable and oppressive.
The attorneys also argued that Fulton County
D.A.
Fanny Willis, his office, initially said their
clients were witnesses, not subjects or targets,
and that they agreed to voluntary interviews.
Although it appears as though that has changed.
This is a very good sign.
It seems Fannie Willis is taking this extraordinarily
seriously.
It appears that on August 2nd, unless something
changes, Senator Lindsey Graham is going to
have to appear and testify not as a target
that we know.
But this is a brazen and direct attempt to
subvert the will of the people, to subvert
democracy.
It was authoritarian and it was fascistic.
The plot was.
And this happened in multiple states.
David fake electors.
What do you mean?
It's.
Is it a fake person?
Like it's a mannequin?
What do you mean?
Now, here's what I mean.
Joe Biden won Georgia, and because Joe Biden
won Georgia, Georgia's electoral votes go
to Joe Biden when you count and try to get
to 270 votes, which is what you need to become
president.
Georgia and all states won by Joe Biden say
put ours in the Biden column and then you
add them up.
And if you get to 270, you become president.
The scam that among others Trump was running
in Georgia and other states was just put together.
A slate of Republican electors have them all
saying, Oh, we, the duly undersigned, are
indeed the electors, and we cast our electoral
votes for Donald Trump, even though Trump
didn't win the state.
That was the idea.
And it's being investigated in a serious manner
in Wisconsin.
It's being investigated in a serious manner
in Arizona, maybe in other states as well.
I don't have the full list in front of me.
And in Georgia and in Georgia, Faneuil is
wants to know who organized you.
This was a thing where there was an elector,
a fake elector in Arizona confronted by a
reporter.
And he said, was this part of like a big plan?
And the fake elector was evasive and didn't
really say anything.
He's like, No, I just showed up.
Well, how did you know where to go and when
to show up?
You might say, Well, I believe Trump won,
but if you want to show up and try to sign
fake elector forms, someone clearly told you
where to go and when to go.
If I wanted to be a fake elector, I wouldn't
just go to the DMV on Tuesday at ten I would.
Someone would tell me This is where we're
meeting to sign papers.
Who was that?
And the guy refused to answer and eventually
walked away.
So Faneuil is just taking this seriously.
In Georgia, the electors have been subpoenaed.
They are going to have to appear unless something
changes.
And maybe we will get answers as to how high
up was the organization of these fake electors.
Very important.
Huge.
This is one of the things where we spoke to
a lawyer involved in this in Wisconsin last
week and he agreed, thankfully, a number of
safeguards prevented these alternate electors
from being.
Sidered legitimate and valid.
But in theory, if you had a motivated governor
and the right things in place, they could
say, Yeah, well, we don't believe Biden won.
We believe Trump won.
And so we're certifying the Republican electors
instead, and then you would have a hellish
situation on your hands.
So we are going to follow this closely.
We'll tell you when they'll be testifying
and what is likely to come of it.
In the meantime, find me on Twitter at David
Pakman.
And remember that we have the next David Pakman
show viewers town hall coming up on Tuesday,
July 26th at 6 p.m. Eastern.
It will stream exclusively on our second YouTube
channel, Pacman Live, and we'll be taking
questions from everybody.
I hope you'll participate more on that later
this week.
The David Pakman Show is an audience supported
program.
You can sign up for membership at join pacman
dot com.
You can use the coupon code big voting 22
for a discount.
Now why would you sign up?
Well, not
only are you supporting our work, which I
hope you think is at least slightly worth
doing.
You also get a daily extra program called
The Bonus Show and you get a commercial free
audio and video feed of the show wherein The
Daily Show is made available to you with no
commercials 5 to 6 hours earlier than when
it goes live to everybody else.
Pretty good perks.
You also get priority handling for hour of
your town halls, the next of which is coming
up on July 26th